ça fait plusieurs mois que bombardier
jongle avec différents scénarios pour se
renflouer financièrement cette fois la
nouvelle de ces mises à pied a même pris
les syndicats par surprise une mise à
pied brune a pour qualité comme ça c'est
pas facile de se relocaliser à salaire
égal exactement ce comment je le prends
c'est moi ce qui me surprend le plus
c'est de l'apprendre des médiaux donc la
famille inquiète ça touche beaucoup de
gens aussi notre entourage
on va regarder moral on encore espérer
vendre des global c'est plate pour tout
le monde les collègues de travail toutes
les jeunes mais l'ambiance à l'intérieur
regarde c'est pas la joie on va essayer
de garder le plus d'employés de
bombardier possible au sein de la
compagnie et pour le reste on fait notre
possible pour l équité avec le respect
et l'empathie et leur offrirait des
bonnes conditions donc 1750 mises à pied
dont près de 1000 à montréal 480 à
toronto et 280 à belfast c'est un
secteur cyclique cette fois ce sont les
avions d'affaires global de 12 places et
moins qui sont touchées en raison d'une
baisse de commandes en provenance d'asie
de russie et même d'amérique latine ben
ça va pas bien ça va pas bien c'est ce
qu'on dise cseries leur temps dans le
développement - demande pour les avions
d'affaires pour cet analyste le nouveau
pdg de bombardier alain bellemare a
d'abord favoriser les marchés financiers
depuis que monsieur bellemare est arrivé
à la tête de bombardier il y avait
vraiment un changement idéologique à la
tête de bombarder c'est à dire qu'on est
passé d'une logique industrielle
ingénierie à une logique financière faut
pas se cacher leur mise à pied ça veut
dire moins de salaire à payer là c'est
ce qu'on tente d'améliorer la position
financière qui ont tant de dépenser
moins le premier ministre philippe
couillard a été interpellé en chambre
sur ces nouvelles mises à pied qu'est-ce
qu'il dit aux pères ou mères de famille
qui ont appris cette semaine qu'il
n'avait plus d'emploi ya quand même
aujourd'hui plus d'employés à bombardier
qu'il y en avait avant la grande crise
financière de 2008 2009 en attendant les
employés chez bombardier fondent tous
leurs espoirs sur l'appareil de la
cseries pour rattraper le terrain perdu
pourtant cet appareil à plus d'un an et
demi de retard et ses coûts de
développement qui s'élève maintenant à 5
milliards de dollars ne cesse
d'augmenter ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal
et on va poursuivre ont changé à la soie
céline c'est un coup dur coup
aujourd'hui mais faut dire que le bilan
chez bombardée depuis un an est assez
difficile oui et c'est ça qui est
inquiétant parce que des compressions
dans le secteur de l'aéronautique à
coups de 500 1000 1500 en position des
choses qui se produisent parce que
beaucoup d'emplois bien sûr dans ces
entreprises là là quand on fait le bilan
depuis janvier 2014 on est à 4 ronde de
compressions g bombardier aujourd'hui
mais 750 janvier 2015 mille juillet 2014
1800 janvier 2014 1700 plus de trois ses
plus de 6000 emplois perdus et plus de
3500 au canada l'addition de ces ronde
de compressions suscite de vives
inquiétudes mais bombardier n'est pas
seul à vivre à sa situation vacances
boeing a coupé deux mille emplois en
2014 airbus se couper 5000 emplois en
2014 beechcraft s'était placé sous la
protection des tribunaux en 2012 est
revenu en 2013 mais la division cessna
quand même coupé 750 emplois en 2014
bell helicopter ya pas très longtemps à
supprimer des emplois aussi igor stream
qui est un concurrent direct à bon
verdict s'en sort assez assez bien mon
parti n'est pas seul avis bien sûr ces
problèmes le problème de bombardier se
son positionnement très exposée aux
aléas économiques et aux aléas
géopolitiques on pense parce que romain
aux sanctions économiques en russie la
pression boursière très forte pression
boursière qui pousse le nouveau patron
alain bellemare à prendre des décisions
comme des compressions élancé bombardier
transport en bourse notamment la cseries
tout est misé sur la cseries le danger
et je termine là tu sais l'insee les
jeunes yade expertise qui est perdu
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
vont se dire y'a pas d'avenir là dedans
pourquoi j'irais étudié en aéronautique
avec toutes ces mauvaises nouvelles tous
ces emplois très spécialisés
oui on le remplit aujourd'hui exactement
seront plus là peut-être c'est ça c'est
une expertise perdu merci beaucoup
gérald hérault céline